[Music]
hi Jase so your question is how
widespread is it within NASA that
scientists are convinced that human
activity is responsible for climate
change and this is something that it's
important to say very very clearly I
have known and worked with hundreds of
earth scientists at many different
locations in NASA all of them all of
them believe that human activity is
responsible for the current climate
change that we see going so fast it's
almost unprecedented I want you to think
about that one thing that I take really
seriously and I'm very proud of is that
NASA is not a political organization we
are scientists I work for the American
people we're funded by taxpayer money
and what we do is we make measurements
we have many many different satellites
that are orbiting the Earth right now
they're looking at things like ice on
the oceans and at the poles they're
looking for things like vegetation
growth and the change of that ocean
level is the ocean level rising yeah it
turns out that it is so we have many
scientists all over the planet studying
all of the different ramifications of
climate change we understand the causes
there actually is no scientific
controversy about that humans are
releasing greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere and this is warming our
planet
now what scientists are researching
currently and they don't all agree about
is what are the most important
components of driving climate change is
it carbon dioxide could it be something
else like methane when methane gets
released that's an even more powerful
greenhouse gas we don't agree on how
quickly things like the ocean level will
rise people have different estimates for
how quickly that will happen so there
still is scientific controversy about
what the most important aspects of
climate change are and how quickly it
will go in the future but there is no
scientific disagreement within NASA that
humans are causing climate change now I
started this off by saying that one of
the things I'm very proud of is that
NASA is not political and what that
means for me is that I cannot advocate
for any specific solution to climate
change that's not my job that's up to
policy makers people might suggest
things like having more solar energy or
cutting carbon emissions or things like
that but at NASA we really understand
that's not us that's up to the American
people our leaders and leaders around
the world what we do is provide the
facts to everybody on the planet all of
our data is actually free to any
government any person any scientist all
over the world that wants to use it so
we all know what's causing climate
change we can't tell you what to do
about it but we can say it's time to do
something about it
[Music]